episode uh I've got my co-host here
today who I whenever I have any kind of
uh watch nerding going on which this
full episode will be uh complete watch
nerding I've got to call if you're a
girl turn off now yeah exactly like oh
done watch it I have to have Kevin
Christie here uh who of course you've
heard us talk uh basil world and and and
that's how we bonded when we first
started at the comedy store when I
started I met him and we've got a great
guest today introduce yourself uh my
name is Bo gory U co-owner of a company
called Los Angeles Watch Works uh
specialize in restoration repair
primarily on Vintage pieces but
contemporary watches as well amazing
because about a week ago I'm at the
store Kevin goes you see this guy he's
cutting into cases and stuff I don't how
do you feel how do you feel about that
and I was like yeah I don't know you
know and I was like [__] you know uh do
you do that and then I meet you the next
day it's so spooky and you walk out and
you go holy [__] Dean Del re you knew me
and you're a comedy fan you're like fan
of Comedy you're like Des Squad man I'm
I'm I couldn't believe it and right away
I was so [__] happy because I go this
is going to be the ultimate guest for us
thanks man appreciate it appreciate you
having me now I I walked in and uh I
you've got an amazing place here out in
Pasadena and I immediately wanted to
know everything about rolex's and we're
going to have a a ton of questions on
watches and movements and everything
let's do it but what your main thing is
you do is most people do a shitty shitty
job at polishing watches they if they
want to sell it or or whatever they want
it to look new which I didn't know back
in the day that you could just polish
the watch and it would look brand new
but I also also didn't know back in the
day that it rounded the edges uh and
really bad for our purposes I mean even
the word polishing is kind of kind of
bad news because when when you think of
polishing especially in terms of watches
you think of like you know Joe Jeweler
with a polishing mop and a bunch of
rouge just you know make the case shiny
and that's you know for collectors like
you you guys myself I mean that's you
know that's bad news so it's more
refinishing and um I mean it took a long
time man took a lot of R&D and just um
kind of reverse engineering how you know
our focus is is primarily you know
vintage Rolex but also dive watches and
other you know cool stuff omegas from
like the 60s and 70s so it took a long
time to kind of reverse engineer because
you know by today's methods I mean with
CNC and you know modern Diamond
abrasives and stuff they do things a lot
differently and that's that's great for
manufacturing not so good for
restoration and repair so we really use
um you know lapping machines and
different grades of abrasive papers and
kind of the old world method of
recutting cases the the way they used to
do it back in the 60s and 70s now are
you the first guy to cut into cases do
you think um no there's other guys doing
it out there um you know there's there's
guys in Switzerland that have been doing
it for a while a couple companies in
Italy that do good work but as far as
the US um you know I think we're the
first people to really kind of focus on
it um cuz for most for most watch makers
and even service centers it's it's um
it's often overlooked aspect you know
they they service movements and and you
know shine up cases and give them back
to clients and you know that's fine and
dandy for for normal people but for
collectors you know case Condition it's
everything yeah it also seems to be an
area that's pretty ripe for [__] up
if you not get it like like the the
level of risk seems pretty because I
looked I I I don't know how I came up on
your Instagram but I was like I looked
at it and you had like two be like uh
bevels side by side or two cases I was
like how the that was 5508 case yeah it
was a 5508 and I was like wait wait wait
I literally was confused I was like I
don't get it cuz it didn't I was like
that looks the same size right and I'm
like that looks like a new like Edge
like brand new I was like I don't I
don't get it I don't get it at all
essentially it is you know yeah and I
and I was like do you add I couldn't
figure it out so I showed you I was like
what the hell do you think of this dude
I don't know what's going on here weird
like is he adding metal because is the
case like when they're doing the ghetto
uh polishing and the case gets rounded
is it just I mean uny detectable amounts
of uh metal coming off that you could
never tell but you could only tell
because of the shape right right it's
not a whole lot of metal coming off I
mean a lot of times depending on how
heavy guys go it does remove a lot of
metal but most times they're just
rounded out is you see some super I mean
especially in Subs you see some rounded
ass subs and took forever for me to like
know what I was looking at after date
just too like old date just sure they're
I mean you seem like that now knowing
I'm like God damn how many times have
you polished this thing yeah but I've
seen some [__] horror stories over
the years guys beautiful watches that
have been just you know that looked I
mean you look at as like the crown
guards and you're like dude that case
was probably unpolished before you know
they took it to a jewelry polishing
wheel and just hammered it now a lot of
these C do you think a lot of these
cases you see with problems they in
theory polished at Rolex cuz a lot of
people were sending them in
unfortunately yeah there there's some
you know
there Rolex is is great H as far as like
doing Factory movement services but they
don't have a collector in mind they very
much have a you know throw away the old
Parts take new ones off the shelf and
for kills it that's their bit they don't
I mean I'm I'm sure they find the
Vintage Market relatively annoying cuz
they would much rather have all of us be
walking into Rolex stores and buying new
watches well there's horror stories of a
guy sending it in with like a uh you
know an old dial that's uh peed and
everything came back with a new dial you
know and there's two mindsets of me on
that like the guys working at Rolex like
this dial is worth paper move it to the
side and put in the new one and a lot of
guys are like wow my watch looks new
again but all of us the same with uh you
know vintage car and guitars you want
all original you want original patina
you want original hands original Loom
everything right I I wonder with how
lucrative the Vintage Market has gotten
and just the old Rolex Market in general
do you foresee there being just fewer
and fewer all original Rolex watches to
the point where things like replaced
hands and lit you know kind of minor
things like that won't be nearly as big
a deal just because of the lack of
numbers of watches available yeah yeah I
I see it moving that way I mean a lot of
stuff is just general wear items tubes
crowns gasket I mean that stuff gets
changed on a routine service but I mean
unless there's water intrusion or or
major damage I mean dial in hand should
should stick with the watch you know
yeah let's talk about the first one you
carved into you had to be [__] in your
pants was it just a shitty one you
bought to practice um no no I uh I've
been doing this for like 15 years so um
which also first fa you don't look like
a watchmaker old how old are you I'll be
38 in December 38 yeah cuz when I when
when the guy said you want to meet the
dude and you came out I thought it was
just going to be an ancient I thought it
was going to be you know Willie Wonka's
Grandpa what's his name Grand Charlie
Charlie's Grandpa Grandpa Joe yeah watch
makers look like owls essentially like
they have two sets of glasses their
hunch their hunch is incredible and
that's kind of you want weird eyebr like
there was a guy I bought an Omega from
that that place on Beverly where where
Craig Evans small used to be oh Cent
I've known Craig for great dude a decade
great dude like I but there was a guy in
there that's really old Israeli guy who
had great prices on omegas but he looked
like an owl like his eyebrows touched
his bangs like it was insane but like
you're like oh you've been in the watch
game a very long time yeah let's talk
about you're 38 and where do you grow up
uh I was born in Arcadia grew up up in
sang Valley so local guy I'm from Locker
there you go there you go so how at what
age and what get you into uh watches cuz
me I told Kevin it was Bond I wanted
everything Bond Rosal skis I wanted the
Lotus of Sprint and I wanted the Rox
what what got you into them um I mean at
finish school did um you know a bunch of
different stuff um you know I wrestled
in school got in Brazilian jiu-jitsu and
muai actually fought a couple of amateur
smokers you know and and decided I
didn't want to get kicked in the head
for a
living one day I wanted I wish I could
go back and see be like this hurts yeah
like hey kind of I feel kind of shitty
today for smaller dudes there wasn't a
lot of opportunity in MMA back then oh
yeah MMA I mean I remember those early
UFC tank abbit against [__] Royce
Gracie well you could you could punch in
that you could do anything you wanted so
guys were just getting punched in the
dick over and over again well it wasn't
just that it was you know uh obviously
the Pinnacle the highest level is UFC
and the lightest weight class they had
was 155 lightweight yeah you know so I
walk around at 150 lbs I'd be fighting
it you know guys cut crazy I'd be
cutting it like 35 you do any bar fights
you getting any bar fights uh not in a
long long time right but I mean back in
the day would you just go out and
[__] do some bar fighting no never
look for it never look for it but I mean
being a you know being a small dude
growing up I mean that's how I ended up
in martial arts in the first place yeah
getting beat up like [__] this ain't
getting beat up anymore so what gets you
into watches so you know did a lot of
different things um you know played
around with the MMA game um worked for a
painting contractor and my dad was a
graduate gemmologist you know he was a
diamond dealer oh wow you know had an
office in downtown are you Jewish no no
wow
no again rare yeah yeah it was it was a
rare thing because my dad was one of the
few American guys who was actually in
the jewelry business and um so kind of
took an interest in his business and um
you know his his partner at the time was
a Rolex trained watchmaker who um you
know worked for the Beverly Hills
Boutique for like 10 or 11 years gir's
uh um no when Beverly they they used to
have just a Rolex service in oh yeah
that's same one a Wisher they closed it
for a long time and then kind of
reopened it but this place is kind of
spooky before we go any further I went
in there one day I was telling cavernous
and empty and weird it's totally empty
cold dark no one in there and I just
walk in and I'm looking around I'm like
uh what's going on and I don't know
where it was like sh a door open and
said hi and I I was like I'm not here
for some religions you know am I in the
hotel of The Shining [__] yeah it was
really weird then they took my watch and
they go we'll be right back and they
came back and they went yes it's real
cuz I went down there to see if it was
real you know like a watch you know well
they're checking serial numbers to see
if it's stolen Oh that's oh wow man this
morning on Instagram I saw a guy post
things some guy got his Lang one stolen
oh yeah what a bum and they were like
this guy saved up this wasn't a rich
dude this was like this was this guy's
Grail watch he saved up for a decade
bought a lang one and some guy ripped it
off him where at off his arm yeah off
off his arm in Europe wow I mean that's
a
$30,000 watch he better had it insured
ho but still it's like godamn it dude so
this guy's my my business partner
actually who I got to mention Eric coup
who um you know being in the watch game
I'm sure I know Eric I know that name
test.com so yeah he's my partner in our
business but he just did a crazy
unboxing on IG of a God it was a lang
but I don't remember what model it was
this morning I'm a I love Lang yeah okay
so your your your father's Partners
Rolex service guy yep started learning
the trade from him and um you were just
into it out of the gate like wow I want
to get into Rolex always kind of
interested in watches but um you know uh
actually bought a couple bought a couple
Rolexes pre-owned Rolexes and what we
talking 15 years 16 years ago yeah 15 16
years
and what models did you buy just
datejust like 1601 163's plastic
datejust which at the time right not
super collectible like they are now so
they were super cheap I know you're
talking you know buy a watch for 8900
bucks wow you know sell it for 12,500
the next day it's pretty good margin I
still think those 1600 161s and 603s are
like the best value oh I love them
they're the they're I've never everyone
I've ever had runs great y they're just
I love them I love them to death there
still reason yeah I get them with like a
nice wide boy dial like a door stop
there there's cool stuff out there to be
had you know I want the Buckley dial I
love the Buckle so you start getting you
start getting into it yeah um and from
you know from buying and selling my own
pieces started working on them and um
you know just okay but that's and you're
like buying some my I started working on
that's not there's I mean I open them up
dude I open it up and he shows it to me
I'm like I don't even know yeah that's a
big there's a there's a big learning
curve in there I to where you're like
like you don't take one of those like
screwdrivers that has three different
nibs and go all right let's check this
out like it's pretty serious it looks it
looks so foreign to 99.9 American
percent of people you also to everyone
listening the parts are to say they're
tiny minuscule is not even accurate
you're you're dealing in micro mechanics
M yeah literally micro mechanics those
magnifying glass head things and like
it's it's serious so like how are you
able to even learn like what is there a
did you get a book or was it just
watching let me back up you know started
working on like shitty courts movements
okay and um just just learned from there
the GU training you your dad's buddy and
how long was he in the game uh he worked
for the service center for Rolex for
like 11 years before he went out on his
own and you know with the Rolex Parts
account and uh what's his name uh AO
Anan still still in the business ao's
watch
shout out to Alo love it yeah love those
dudes so you start you start learning
from him and what kind of stuff are you
learning because um you said something
to me a lot of people don't know this
and Rolex and and automatic movements uh
the the certification is plus five or
minus five seconds a day means fine
right right it's uh the governing body
is CC um you know certified official IAL
uh Swiss
chronometers yeah they they say it in a
much cooler accd yeah right yeah so to
be a
chronometer uh you know that's that's
the regulation needs to be plus minus 5
Seconds a day and so how what are the
some of the first thing you're learning
how to adjust that is that like the
major first thing you're going to learn
watch timing adjustments on automatic
and Perpetual movements is like one of
the last things really what is the first
stuff you're learning like lubrication
just um getting basic understanding of
the gear train and how how things are
powered and um you know every aspect of
that so in in a did you primarily
focused solely on Rolex in the beginning
uh yes yeah does does learning how to
service a Rolex make it so that learning
other brands is relatively easy or
harder or they are they incredibly
different or are they all kind of
similarish um pretty similarish as far
as Perpetual movements go um all the I
mean the thing about Rolex for me and a
lot of other big Brands AP mentioned
elang um is just repeatability you know
uh a lot of watch brands out there you
can't you know from a technician
standpoint I mean you can't take them
apart and put them back together they
screws Break Stuff strips out okay you
know the Best Brands you know you can
take them apart put them back together
10 times nothing breaks you know General
wear items are replaced but what do you
think is the most overrated incredible
expensive brand of watches you're to you
you're like why are [__] buying these
no offense you nailed it I knew h b our
[__] dude [__] everybody hates
them you know the guys that love them
you know why I can't stand that watch it
has no [__] soul yeah it has no soul
it just screams to tells time it just
screams to me like uh Ed Hardy [__]
shirt and uh Schwarzenegger you know
kind of big watch and they just have no
soul it's just like hey let's round off
an AP Royal Oak yeah yawn like like we
all haven't thought that like big like
we got to put screws on it why for guys
that have dicks like you're just like so
boring they take you know at a movement
off the shelf decorate the oscillating
weight done no it's they're boring when
I see people with him and like sometimes
guys be like hey I I heard you on this
podcast you're a watch guy what you see
and show me a
I'm like yeah man good job like cuz I
know it's I love this site the purest
I've I've always loved it and what I
liked about what I've always liked about
it is there's like a they have like a
code you're not allowed to be rude right
you're literally not if if someone posts
a watch I don't care if it's the okay
you know that weird cheetah Daytona sure
yeah I love
itler It's oddly gross so [__] weird
great you're like you're rich and weird
you're like this is the only Ro stepen
Tyler could own yeah but like you could
post that thing and if anyone's like
ugly like you get booted which is to me
great because watches are expensive
right and if you like that hublo and you
came up with the 19 Grand to buy like
God bless like I'm glad you like it I
wouldn't buy it that's not my [__] but
then again if I showed you watches I
think are worth of money you'd be like
that is so dumb yeah why do you want
that old piece of [__] for 50 Grand also
also I know that Ro is not the best
watch on the planet and we know that and
to a lot of people I try to explain it
like Kevin and I say this is just a blue
call or high ticket item it doesn't even
count in the rich game you know people
go oh you got a Rolex you're a baller
not even
close turbion that are 250 g well not
only that but it's like I got this Rolex
you probably smoke cigarettes every day
or buy two Starbucks a day you can have
a Rox just cut out the Starbucks and at
the end of the year you got any Rox they
make
um it's the dirt i' I've told you I like
it cuz it's the dirt bag watch it's like
successful tattoo
artist skaters mechanics artists it's
like it's the thing you buy when you
made more money than you thought you
would make doing the thing people told
you you probably shouldn't do right or
or you got some kind of weird bump of
cash that you didn't think was coming
like [__] it sub although when I meet
watch makers they all just have a Rolex
I know they're just like they have a sub
date just cuz like yeah this thing runs
well it's Dependable yeah it's a good
investment you came you came in with the
new um with the new sub right and uh you
could potentially really wear anything
right I mean I mean like what do you
think is the best for me it's vintage um
what's your Grail yeah full spec 557 mil
sub yeah wow or 6538 big Crown you know
we're
fing that's my [__] I love 550 wait I'm
a simple lady yeah yeah so you're you're
a Rolex guy if you could have any watch
on the planet yeah for sure over patch
and everything I like PEX um I like
working on them very well made but um
you know I I'm a rough guy you know and
and I I need something that I can kind
of beat up a little bit Yeah that's the
that's the thing about why why I think a
lot of people like Rolex you just put it
on you don't have to worry about cuz I
had a l i had an 1815 manual wind which
is it's so stunning and honestly you I
didn't have to I barely touched the
crown it started running cuz like you
literally it was like it knew I was
about to wind it like it was like oh
Kevin's ready like the thing and the
movement was beautiful but it was gold
and I would like worry about bumping it
all the time I didn't wear it that much
I heard someone had a great quote it was
in a magazine it was like your watch
shouldn't change the way you walk like
you shouldn't tuck it behind your back
you shouldn't like hide it under your
sleeve wow that's an amazing quote yeah
it shouldn't change the way you behave
at all and I think that's why like I I
was I've been I'm going to buy a watch
pretty soon and I can't pick cuz in my
price range there's a lot to pick from
and they're all like Rolexes that are
cool so I'm just like looking at HQ
every day like like over and over and
over again but I found this great
picture of Paul Giamatti just wearing
like the most normal sub ever and I was
like that's that's what I want there's
something about a guy's like I just need
a [__] give me one of those Rolexes
like I don't want to think about it I
want to just put it on and get it wet
like a top every years I it toone like
you I get it back and it's like it's
just you don't have to wor about it [__]
mine doesn't even have the date on it
yeah now why did you choose no date
since you're a watch guy is it different
classic classic just C original sub no
date clean face yep yep I like base
models um you know I like base models
too yep I like military watches hence
the NATO um no frills you know it does
its job nothing it shouldn't everything
it should done what do you think about
the Boom and speed Masters that's
happened what happened there it's crazy
dude I mean what happened there I got my
ass kicked on one two years ago Dean
sells one for me for like $3,000 it took
M21 or 861 a 321 10 uh it was a
1454 and it took forever to sell I mean
it was like and now it's $8,000 it's
been like the last I don't know year 18
in there did someone wear one that we
didn't see all a sudden that auction I
mean the auctions definitely help I've
always thought speed Masters are a lot
of watch for the money it's that's what
I've always thought they were underated
great Aesthetics good history you know
moonlanding yeah um and I they've been
undervalued a long time I think they
finally just you know made it up to I
mean the like the Chuck Jagger GMT yeah
is worth a fortune and it didn't go on
the [__] moon like yeah yeah like if
any Rolex had record yeah if any Rolex
had a history half as like as cool as
going to the Moon who even like if there
was a Daytona if there was the moon
Daytona oh yeah it'd be
$180,000 it' be insane explore 1016 went
to the uh M Everest and that thing sells
for some good money it's so simp it
wasn't a 1016 though before 6610 I right
that's the yeah the 66 now in the last
two weeks Cokes have gone through the
roof all of a sudden they were 5500
bucks all day and then the last two
weeks all of a sudden they're 8,500
bucks yeah isn't that crazy like it just
happens out of nowhere see it makes me
wonder what's going to happen with all
the you know the you know 16610 and all
the basic Sapphire models before they
went with the the new case and the
ceramic bezel you were talking about the
cokes the 16 710s the green frog what's
are are those going to Skyrocket cuz you
saw what sea dwellers did yeah yeah but
then sea dwellers have calmed down a bit
Yeah in the last like month I think sea
dweller is one of those things were like
the average guy doesn't they're like why
is that different right and they're like
so why does that want a grand more it
looks like I remember having to explain
to my ex-wife why I had both of them I
had a sub and a c different honey she's
like they look I I was like no they're I
sound
stupid 16 610 to me are interesting
because there's got to be millions of
them oh yeah so 800,000 watches a year
Rolex 800,000 a year they yeah not not
your subs right but still 500 are
probably Subs yeah it's a lot of so you
figured there's there's literally a
couple million out there so demand's
never going to be like high but fake
demand could be kind of high like you
know places like Bob watches is sitting
on like I don't know 70 like they
probably just have tons of them but for
me that's what I'll probably end up
getting because that they're really
reasonable and I think a really good
value oh yeah definitely and like I you
know you that's a watch you'll have for
20 years and maybe it'll go up but like
I had a Matt dial 16800 love that watch
and it took forever to go up like those
you could find cheap all like they were
like people were like oh they didn't
like they didn't care it was like the
bastard of a 1680 like no no no no no
that like I want the new dial yeah I
went to what's his name in the deep
valley the guy John May sued and he was
like we have 10 of these and like and he
was like Bob's or the guy like he's
convinced these are going to be a
$10,000 watch one day I was like yeah in
like 11 years yeah do you know anything
on that John mer thing what happened no
I know it was over Daytona I guess I
think more than one cuz he sued him for
like 7 00 Grand I think it was I think
it was like seven cuz I've seen I wasn't
supposed to see this but I saw a picture
of of mayor's Daytona pile yeah it was
upsetting wow he's got a crazy
collection man yeah he does he never
talks about the Rolex collection he's
always talking about IWC and videos and
[__] but like I mean there were like 50
yeah wow and they were these were and
how many newans a ton dude all newans
almost all and and part of me was like
Hey I don't even think there are that
many out there and if you're buying them
at that rate
you're not doing a the necessary due
diligence for watch cuz you
hear told me a guy came in and was like
I want to sell this Newman he's like I
had to look the guy in the face and be
like this is a fake dial and I knew he'd
paid 55 grand right like what do you
even do call the FBI yeah let's get into
some fake stuff here terrifying when I
talked to you said that you could put a
watch in your hand close your eyes and
know it was fake you've been doing this
so long indeed uh how do you know it's
fake are they making fake movements are
the what what is everything about fake
now interestingly enough in terms of fix
Rolexes are the easiest to spot really
yeah because Rolex for all intents and
purposes everything is perfect wow you
know so when you look close I mean you
know if the serifs are off yeah uh the
the indices the bezel font um the way
you know the threads on the case tube
the you know the the crown on the crown
on the crown the U just everything
there's so many I notic when you when
like a lot of times you take and watch
the first thing people they'll flip it
over and look at the Cal stamp the look
at the stamp on the bracelet yeah is
that a I've I've read that that's a big
one because fake fake people they're not
they're not stamping it they fake
engrave it right and so it looks
different cuz it stamp has like almost
like on the case yeah yeah they're
almost like die struck like a coin on
the on the the blades yeah so it's it's
hard to get them perfect yeah well if
you're if you're engraving it by hand
it's hard to get it he said like the
edge of the numbers almost have like a a
bevel to them yeah that's that's what I
noce a lot of people point because it
used to be I always looked for the the
magnification the date right because
usually that's not big enough right like
I saw a fake pan right right away and
the the magnifying eye was too small now
are you seeing fake movements like where
it says Rolex and everything on the
movement or did you just open the back
and go this is fake the I mean when you
open up I mean the the biggest thing
that jumps out on Rolex movement are the
reversing wheels that those two purple
reversing wheels are those plastic no no
no no they're not they look like they
look like magnesium or something the
pink ones are the pink ones I always
thought that was plastic plastic wow
thank God I was like why do they run
these plastic Wheels in here I never
knew that okay so you open up and you
you know if you look for those are there
but now I mean I've seen I've seen
movements with you know correct looking
reversing Wheels the the bridges are
decorated properly I mean they're
they're built to deceive really yeah big
time and wow so you think it could go by
a watch seller like say he buying
watches he opens go that's real and just
puts it in a pile without really looking
at it yeah yeah I mean if if you've done
of them enough man and you looked at
enough watches you just you just know
it's almost like a six sense no [__] huh
but there's like I said Rolexes are are
the hardest to fit because everything
has to be perfect but there's a lot of
other brands like I've seen some really
scary paniz recently piz cuz that
movement is simple yeah it's a you know
it's a value you know and also APS I saw
a Royal Oak not that long ago this I saw
I saw an offshore and I [__] you not it
had a real clasp and real you know
alligator strap on it one of those big
Ridge Gators the strap alone's 500 bucks
yeah you know case screws movement you
know how the the the date magnifier is
actually on the dial I mean so good wow
wow so what was fake on it then
everything except the the strap the
clasp and it was hard to tell man the
dial might have even been real but the
case was fake the movement was fake wow
and did you tell the guy or did he know
he had a fake oh well it was it was a
dealer who came to me to get it
authenticated wow yeah so he's like
should I buy this thing is it kosher
yeah no now when a watch comes in and a
guy wants to get it serviced have you
had a guy who's owned a watch for years
he brings it into get service and you go
this is fake I've had to yeah and what
just happens man heartbreak you know we
have to tell them for liability purposes
you know but but yeah yeah because if
you don't he's going to think you
switched out [__] Heen forbid if at a
later date you know we work on the watch
without mentioning it and he somebody
else inspects it you know it could come
back to us and you that's what I'm
saying they think that you swapped out
the movement and stuff I know a dude who
got what he thought was an explor 1016
as a gift but it was one of those oyster
perpetuals they just put in the dial
yeah and that like that's what sucks is
you're like it's all Rolex but all wrong
yeah and it's it's weird because it's
watch it's the difference between a
$2,500 watch and a $7,000 watch at the
time wow that's what that's the [__]
that terrifies me CU early on when I
didn't know anything I bought what I
thought I bought a 1680 and I was like
this one's really cheap and I realized
like oh cuz it has a replac dial like it
had and I was like dial or refinish dial
it said Swiss okay so I wasn't yeah I
bought it from a a dude you know yeah
but I wasn't so I wasn't he didn't lie
to me I just didn't know enough right
like I looked at the do I was like it
says Rolex and then I took it home I was
like man this thing glows real bright
for something that's from
1968 I was like and I was like Swiss
versus T25 God damn it so I had to go to
wab BU a watch be like you got any 1680
dials in hand they like yes we do how
much 600 bucks God damn it so I paid oh
at the time yeah well back then Craig
Evans small and wab byat had Parts yeah
cuz Craig told me he bought out like a
serer from Orange County and got like
you this is like 2005 you could go into
craigman small shop and be like I need a
bracelet he' be like no problem and sell
you an oyster bracelet for like
$400 which now a he doesn't have any no
one does like in the world like I should
have just bought bracelets back then
yeah Bez look look at bezel inserts oh
dude he had boxes of them and do you got
bezel inserts I got some stuff yeah most
of them now I mean I've sold so many of
them over the years most of them is kind
of like my personal little honey pod
super ghost inserts now when you we
servicing Rolex you're using Rolex parts
right do you call them and can you get
bezel inserts from them and stuff not
vintage ones but Yeahs can you get the
frog one cuz mine has a scratch those
they only do uh I think on an exchange
basis or you might even have to send it
into them because they they don't want
people just taking like a regular
slapping that Bez on yeah yeah yeah wow
all right yeah I used to have a lot more
parts over the years but they've all you
know been used over the years now how
now let's get back into it so you get
you you start to cut into a case right
uh how do you do this do do you do it by
computer you is it eye is it hand you're
going to cut into a case and you're
going to make the case back to original
sharp edges right It's All About Angles
um you know we talked earlier about the
word polishing you know versus
refinishing
um in a lot of ways it's kind of like
polishing a katana you know um we don't
we don't polish we we step down in
grades of abrasives and that's how you
keep things flat like what do you do so
um you know anybody who's got experience
in the watch games heard of lapping
machines uh so what it is I should have
should have brought some pics of my
equipment um you've got a a turning disc
you know face up and you've got
adjustable tables and Jigs and tooling
to hold cases so you can present them to
the wheel on a consistent angle right
right okay oh that's how they get in the
round cuz they just cuz I seen like
buffer wheels and the guy just like
that's how you polish a ring not a watch
yeah I seen guys do that yeah it's like
hey let me see your watch I'll make it
look brand well you go to Ben Bridge and
they be like do you want us to polish
your watch while you look at something
yeah go ahead back that's how used
that's like the number one sin I mean
you never polish a watch with the
movement inside you know oh wow really
that's all I mean dude wow no [__] huh
yep so you're cutting into it and what
are you using like um is it like a
lightsaber like a like a Dremel or
something like the tooth [__] no we
never use hand tools I mean a lot of it
I'll be completely honest it's some of
it's trade secret oh I got you I'm cool
with that I'm cool with that I got you
you know we can do what we do and
there's not a lot of other people doing
it yeah but that's the thing when I
looked at that picture I was like uh I
don't I was like I don't what's going on
here yeah I was like what's this is a
secret yeah cuz I never see it and I
look I mean I'm looking yeah we're on
Instagram all day long I've never seen a
uh you know the bevel cut like that so I
was like wait this is new [__] and I was
genuinely confused right now I had Brian
the boot maker on and he said yeah he
said uh Instagram changed his game and
you told me two days ago Instagram
changed the watch business 100% how do
you think especially in vintage stuff I
mean you know there's a small little
Core group of guys dealers Us in the
trade that you know I've always been hot
on Vintage but yeah you know at least me
personally you get on Instagram the
whole world man I had no idea there were
so many vintage collectors as well as
vintage dealers you know there there's
guys with stuff you stuff you wouldn't
believe you know at all parts of the
world those get together pictures are
terrify right the big piles the big
piles you're like how much here's what
my only problem with the watch game is
this a lot of the real hardcore
collectors are just kind of money Geeks
yeah and you're like oh you know no
they're not dudes you want to hang out
with necessar it's not like my least
favorite type of picture in watches is
the hand on the steering Ferrari
steering wheel the watch that I like I'm
like sweet watch and then the cigar I'm
like dude you're the worst I'm like I'm
not hanging out with you ever like you
have nothing in common besides that
watch here's another photo I hate the
the Primo watch with nine bracelets
around just scar taking chunks out of
scaring in the watch I look at the
bracelet I'm like that's a metal piece
on the bracelet assho unbelievable right
especially me I'm the one who has to fix
that [__]
like okay big question here since I ride
motorcycles and a lot of people uh
listen that ride motorcycles while
riding does it fect the movement at all
from the handlebars and riding and stuff
no no not at all not with modern inkor
block I mean the way that that uh the
balance is set up and you know the
capules and yeah no vibration is really
not an issue no [__] that's rad to know
that is great I jumped out of plane
shoot shot guns scuba dive I do yeah I
would think gun shooting yeah on like
but like if if you had like an incred
like this this my this old sea master I
have I it's probably pretty Del not
delicate but just in comparison more
delicate like like a motorcycle or
shooting guns may like just rattle the
movement like this doesn't keep the best
time I told him I lose like maybe 15
seconds a day not bad not bad for a
watch this old it drives me insane but
like I still like I just said yes for
vintage pieces man if it bugs me if well
for modern stuff yeah but for vintage
pieces man if I'm what five 10 minutes
good enough [__] I've been spoiled cuz I
had a 1675 that I sold and shouldn't
have man I swear to God this thing lost
2 seconds a day I couldn't believe it I
W it was FL I couldn't I you know I I
went to the atomic clock I like synced
it up and I made a note I was like okay
at this time it was this and I went back
I was like are you [__] me this is
the it was the tightest movement I've
ever owned in myre life I had it for
like six months then I wore it on the
motorcycle for like a year like six
months or so he bought it and then or
did you did you no I just I just I gave
sold it for yeah I was selling it for
him but it wasn't selling so I just wore
it around and then a buddy bought it so
great A buddy of mine bought it and
he'll sell it back to Kev right now
why'd you let it go I needed money I
have a dog that's incredibly expensive
he's become his two or three Rolex oh
dude my dog's a Daytona right now he my
dog's a legit mid90s Daytona with box
and papers Dam well it's like it's like
you were you touched on before I mean I
know I know guys who you know my
father-in-law makes a ton of money
where's where's the timx you know
where's IR man rich people are weird
like that I Know Rich guys shops at
Costco for clothes well it's either it's
either your thing or it isn't you know
and I I know guys who you know just make
an okay living they got two three
different Rolexes wear one sell it buy a
new one my buddy Nate and I always talk
about this uh this dude Nate white he
works for Fender he's big watch guy and
he's like yeah shitty car nice watch
yeah and he's like you know a Rolex and
a RAV four like I I'm not a car guy
necessarily but like I I like an I just
like a nice watch yeah tutor how you
liking their game uh uh I like it I like
it a lot I like all the reissues I like
I like what they're doing uh in housee
movement yep the black Bay the ranger
Pelos that's how you say right Pelos
yeah I think all that stuff's killer I
like that small one that's like their
date chest yeah is that a ranger they
have a small Ranger they have a big
Ranger too uhhuh yeah that small one's
classy looking yeah you know what
they're doing which is very very genius
and I I always thought that Harley
should do this they have such a history
and such a a thing they could mine and
and tutor was so smart they were like
[__] it here's our blue snow fake right
now you immediately I was in Kevin and I
we love them man we're like look at this
black Bay man I think they are just with
guilt dials and everything what a home
run right for no money do you do you
think tutor is like a testing ground for
Rolex where they try certain things and
see how it does I don't know I mean you
saw how long it took Rolex to actually
change the case on sub you know they are
creatures of the dial on a Daytona yeah
right I think that I mean we talked
about that last night I think that's the
secret to their success yeah they're so
consistent that like people that have
don't know anything about Watchers know
what a sub looks like y whereas you go
back to the 70s and there were some
companies making some of the jous Disco
crap dude that's some of the stuff I
really enjoy working all all all those
60s and 70s divers you know some of the
stuff L jeans made um I've recently
gotten into L jeans a little bit cuz
Malcolm X wore a cool one yeah he had
like a really and by the way they're
they're not expensive you can find great
manual wine ones for very little money
they're cool looking they're so simple
looking yeah there's a couple that I
think they have like a star on the dial
like they're cool looking yeah yeah that
that's kind of been like my shiny new
toys all the um like Starburst cases
like the Mark I Omega and all a lot of
the early divers that did that I love
working on those I want a mark HQ is a
Mark I right now but it has new hands
but I want a Mark I reum I don't know
how how do you re no they're no they
they're new hands oh okay how do you
reloom hands do you paint it on um this
is awesome I'm so glad you're here once
again secret little bit of tra secet I
got where do you buy loom take out take
out luminous material and use our
special little blend and it in there and
and you can't can you do do you age it
antique it a little absolutely yeah to
match the dial plots I've had I've had a
wow are you hearing that aging hands
doesn't actually bother me matching
hands like oh oh this I literally want
to ask this cuz I tried to sell a watch
to a a reputable dealer in Orange County
that has a very popular website and lots
of banner ads that everyone seen and he
was like ah hands are different color
than the dial hands Aging in a different
paste in the dial absolutely common cuz
he I now I believe you I think they use
it as a means to buy your watch for much
lower price right which is fine that's a
fine thing people are trying to make
money it's fine but it seem I I can't I
don't know is it as common as it as it
seems and what what do you think is the
cause of that oh that's a million dollar
question is it that the loom is on a
matte dial which is essentially plastic
versus being surrounded by metal right
um I don't know there there's a there's
a lot of information and misinformation
about about patina how it happens what
causes it um I personally think it's a
mix of of UV and and ozone well there's
all those Costa Rican Rolexes where the
patina is insane cuz they're soose to
the equator or whatever yeah I mean that
makes total sense to me yeah heat yeah
heat and light have you have you able to
master let's say you got a a a a Pepsi
from five years ago it was super clean
could you age that thing in your office
to make it look like faded and
everything have you mastered that yet
like relicing like guitars they do with
Fender and and and Gibson Tom Murphy
they can age guitar to look like a 59 at
first it looked kind of cheesy but right
now it's starting to look good a lot of
guys have tried that out there I mean as
far as that goes I mean that would just
be you know taking the Luminous material
out of the out of the dialon hands and
and putting something in you know uh the
darker patina looking in there maybe
aging the dial there's a lot of guys who
have done it over the years um there's
one company and I have no connection to
them whatsoever but uh Tempest Machina
yeah if you've seen him he does uh like
a modern version of the big Crown yeah
oh yeah and he just made the 369 mhm
that's right I really like what those
guys are doing what about the other
brand Bamford do you like them um I've
never personally handled any it's a
little disco right they got some pretty
wild mods yeah yeah I I almost think for
them I'd rather have bamford's super
weird ones than just like a slightly
different one well I would all I mean if
I get some big paper the Bamford [__]
uh Brutus is coming to the house that's
weird it's just so [__] weird Brut
watch if you want to go cartoon weird
get a [__] Snoopy Omega it's genuine
oh no well we love that I love snoy
speed master I got crowned on the new
one man I was supposed to get it and
then all of a sudden those things went
for 20 grand and all the dealers went we
don't have any yeah that's another
company I like what they're doing uh you
know the all the reissues like the
straight L spey they're doing the new
the new speed master and the new that
new Bon C Master nice hell yes 369 watch
the 369 yeah the new Mark iOS are cool
looking too yeah yeah I just worked on
one recently oh really yeah I love a
Mark I the shape it's it's like if you
want the size of a panai but not having
to wear a pany right if you don't want
to wear a pan like pany don't sit on my
wrist right but that that dial is
[__] sweet I used to have a lot I
used to have quite a few pany but how
about this my favorite watch one of the
top five and we'll get into some
favorite watches it's panai 203 yeah
have you ever seen one in person JJ
Abrams has one it'swe A 203 it's got a
Rox movement in there yep yep the
Angeles yeah what that's that's what
that's the aspect about panai I like and
I think at least in my opinion that's
what they should have stuck with is
their historic line you know like the
372 that came out exactly the the you
know the original the original special
editions the 217 the 127 like I love all
that stuff the marina military all but
all the crazy turbon and ceramic case
and you know 10 different Limited
Editions every year it's it's Overkill
you know it's like the it's like I like
I like AP I think they're cool but I
don't need a shack AP right I don't need
and by the way I [__] love Sha but I
don't need them together I love Stallone
but I don't need a slide Tech yeah you
know what I mean here's the thing I
always wonder why the [__] these
companies it's so easy cuz right now uh
the big big secret is watch industry is
down and they're trying to keep that a
secret but basil World they talked this
year it's horrible Paddock did a price
decrease for the first time in history
panai did one panai did I didn't know
Patek did one yeah oh yeah that's insane
think about the effect that had on
dealers who had a bunch of stock yeah
you know they're like oh [__] that's th
I mean that's millions and millions
although the you know thing is the new
patex are ugly as [__] you think so yes
they look the dials have no poetry to
them anymore like when I look at the
chronographs it looks like every aspect
of it was designed in AutoCAD there's no
it doesn't look like cuz I loved for me
it's Aesthetics right it's dials and the
new chronographs look like they were
designed in entirely on a computer there
seems to be like no sense of just like
natural design or natural order to the
dials in the same way and it's very
subtle but there's just something off to
them I mean they're def definitely using
more technology in production although
the first the first watch I ever liked I
was like 19 and I'm driving on hill in
Chinatown and there's that Rolex dealer
they have Rolex and Patch they had a
giant poster of a patch world time and I
was like that looks like a cool watch
I'll go home and look up this name oh
it's
$28,000 that and I mean a 59 a 5960
that's the chronograph right yeah that
one I was like that watch is that watch
is incredible expensive for a
chronograph I think it's $70,000 wow but
I mean old patex pre- like 2000 to me or
you know you can't really beat him yeah
my Grail is the my Grail watch right now
is the uh Platinum 40 day date with the
honeycomb dial I think's nice it is
[__] killer honeycomb dials honeycomb
dials are God platinum's a pain in the
ass to work with but it
looks soft yeah it's it's the surface is
very soft but trying to get damage out
of it a lot a lot of companies
manufacturers won't even finish their
own Platinum watches oh wow like take
good care of them or you're on your own
really so what do you see D do you see
Den yeah Den Nicks that's why like white
gold is is a lot easier it's got kind of
looks the same except it's a lot easier
you know after sales what do you think
people should buy um like what do you
think's the best stainless steel white
gold yellow gold Platinum what do you
think as far as like I mean not value
because all those Exotic Metals go down
right away but if you're wearing every
day stainless steel steel of course yeah
yeah right titanium's cool if you want a
lighter watch oh yeah oh yeah like the
new
Pelos TI is that [__] bulletproof um
it's you're never going to break it it's
got a very high tensile strength but the
surface again is a little bit soft so it
scratches easy oh wow but unlike
Platinum it's a lot easier to bring back
to its original finish wow what do you
think what's your least favorite Rolex
yeah ah least favorite Rolex that when
you see people wearing them you're like
what the [__] that's a hard one man
um or and also what what do you think's
the most like underrated Rox that you
wonder why they're not more cuz I wonder
why white dial Explorer 2os aren't more
popular these things are a dollar yeah
Explorer 2 polar I would say I have to
agree with you as far as like it's got a
great movement yeah it's like and
they're cool looking they don't make
many white dials so you're not going to
see it and you know people always
complain like I don't want to Rox cuz
you're going to see it all the time well
then get an Explorer too yeah yeah you
never see him and I love a metal B
yeah I like the new daytonas but I like
a steel bezel on that the old Daytona
better that's that's another thing I
love working on is is is recutting those
Explorer bezels oh really everybody
[__] them up they look you know you
mean the numbers or the edge everything
really can you just buy the new bezel
and screw it on no they don't screw on
they press on but if we're dealing with
collectible [__] like a mark1 bezel
Explorer you want that Big Font bezel
there's actually four surfaces to that
thing what there's a laed edge on top
and then there's the the satin side
finish and then there's another lap
polish Edge on the on on the edge and
then there's even another um spun finish
Edge on the very bottom are you kidding
me dude setup time recutting one of
those they look really simple but it
takes an hour of setup time and five
minutes to actually process it that's
insane because that watch is so
underrated you know I think what really
[__] up the new one was those giant
fat hands you don't like them it's kind
of a nod to the 1655 I think the markers
are the problem the markers are too big
the hands Max markers the Maxi markers
with the hands it was like too much and
the case is Big the case is bigger than
this my friend has one and he doesn't
wear it he was like dude I'll sell it to
you for a song so I wore it for a week
and I was like I don't like this thing
the one thing I do like that they did
with these cases is with uh the Explorer
as well as the GMT they upsize the
crowns for sure for sure they always
have the little that used that's what
kept me that's why 5.3 crown on that
huge it was funny because on that coke
uh at the office I thought this is a
fake crown it was so small what is that
that's just I as far as the theory
behind it I don't know you know it's not
it's not it wasn't marketed as a dive
watch it's a pilot watch so you don't
crash in the
ocean I got it so the big ones are cuz
you're wearing dive gloves and [__] uh
that and more gaskets oh there's more
gaskets cuz Going Down Deeper yeah the
one on the the GMT you're talking about
just has two gaskets one inside the case
tube one inside the crown whereas sub
crowns there's a gasket in the crown and
three gaskets inside the tube and one at
the base of the gasket are you kidding
me technically there's four four gasket
I think I think because of the Bruiser
GMT that came out the the regular GMT to
me is like a sleeper it's like
underrated it's underrated the one with
the green hand now and the green riding
that's the [__] best deal out there
right now besides that brand new for a
brand new Rolex I think that one's
especially used you can find them
reasonable that thing's tough as [__]
great movement it looks cool like you're
not going to see it that often because
everyone wants the BL the Batman right
which the Batman is cool as [__] I'm
sorry you're like the Batman I what what
they need to do is you know the the new
uh the new Pepsi unbelievable white gold
they make that thing in Ste we know that
color that stinks you don't like it so
Red's wrong the red is wrong well the
blue you know what you know what it
looks like to me it's super looks are
Deco like um old um what was that what's
that weird stuff back in the day like
people would collect uh [__] I forget
what it's called it's like a plastic for
mic or whatever B bakerite it's like
bake aite um like the early ones 542 it
looks like old it looks like aged Bake
Light yeah it really does it it it looks
like almost clay you know I'm seeing a
lot of broken ones already I think they
might be having a problem with it well I
always heard when that first came out it
was like oh this GMT is cool and a and
the guy there used to be a guy named Tim
who worked at wannab bu a watch who I
loved he was he just he wasn't like the
watchmaker an expert but he loved
watches and he was like super passionate
he was the nerd I could go in and nerd
out with but he was like yeah that bezel
if you break it it's 1,000 bucks how
much is the bezel th000 yeah they're
like 1,500 bucks really no [__] way
so this but so this one story yeah is it
breaking more than the black one yeah I
think it's it's something it's just that
insert cuz it's it's way more common the
black inserts and even the you know the
other GMT inserts it's not happening now
I read that it was 1,500 to 12200 replac
but recently on the Rolex Forum I'm
seeing 250 and people are saying that
was a [__] the high price 250 for a
ceramic insert that's super cheap no way
you know what though you know honestly
if I broke an insert I would have
someone to glue it together together
with the pieces it look kind of cool I
mean to be honest it would look kind of
badass insert you see you see broken
bake lights sometimes like they' they've
glued them to where they stick your like
dude I've repared a ton of bake lights
really dude talk about being nervous I
mean dude forget it you're you're
[__] playing with a $10,000 piece of
60y old
pre-plastic just the piece is 10 grand
just the piece if you can find like you
know a near New Old Stock honest genuine
6542 bezel yeah it's 10
I want to ask about how do you fix it uh
it depends on how bad it's screwed up I
mean a lot of them they just get you
know like a couple cracks in them so you
just you know you carefully glue them
back reinforce the back yep uh okay
reinforce the back epoxy them back
together and then um same thing use a
little too much of of given epoxy and
sand it down and then polish it and how
do you practice that cuz you're only
doing like one maybe every couple years
the guy comes in can you fix this you're
like yeah a lot of people trip out they
you know like your friends and clients
come in and they'll you know see me
working on something they're like Jesus
man like slow down take it easy you know
that's a $115,000 Caso working with but
we've done so many of them and it it's
muscle memory you know you've done the
same process so have you ever [__] up
like uhoh oh yeah yeah no I've screwed
up in the in the early days I mean now
like like early tattooers like early
work like why that have three ears yeah
right do you ever see some of your early
work guy comes in you're like oh yeah a
couple dealers I worked with you know
have you know every once in while I'll
turn up on a with a piece I worked on
like 10 years ago or something I'm like
not that it looks bad and by most
people's standards it looks like a good
job but you know to my eye I'm like [__]
where do you okay there's a site I go to
all the time and for some reason they
just have they have a lot of omegas but
ton of them they refer to as like dial
has expert restoration I don't know why
they have so many with restored dials
where do you what do you consider just
like when you get say you got an old
Omega right what do you consider just
like cleaning up the dial on the watch
versus
restoring H it depends on how what their
definition of rest do you think
restoration is like adding new material
like like maybe like like like
repainting a marker or like adding Loom
like things like that I mean repainting
is is the you know that that's a deal
breaker for me right when the Dial's
washed and and re you know refinished
and repainted and Rel logoed yeah that's
what if it's just what do you what if
it's just watched like if you get a dial
that just has been weathered and it's
you know it's pening maybe there's Lo
you're worried that some of those pieces
are going to be loosened and maybe get
into the movement do you like clean it
yeah and that's not really do you
consider that restoration like a spider
dial I was reading in New York Times Did
you read that article a couple months
ago maybe a month ago where they were
saying I was telling Kev about it where
they were talking about spider dials
they were talking about tropical dials
and they were talking about um patina
dials and they were saying how they were
going up and people are buying them as
an investment and they were saying cool
investment but if the dials change and
just you know fall you know stuff falls
apart in there and everything all a
sudden your watch is not worth 120,000
or whatever it's going to be down to
30,000 you know I mean it's weird that
what Rolex considers manufacturing flaws
like the spider dialer the cream dial
Explorer or dials to go Tropical what
they see as screw-ups have turned
extremely valuable I think that's just a
product of their consistency that the
only difference is like oh that GMT has
says no they forgot to put the date on
or they didn't say date floating six on
the Daytona like all these strange
little things fat lady GMT to me my
whole life I'm like I don't okay I don't
really get this do you get a bigger case
right it's a case right and what' they
do it one year uh no they did it a
couple years was it a case from another
was it like a is it a subase well it's
got its own serial it's got its whole
model number it's a
16760 and so it's the same height as a
sea dweller of the same era right just
with the the 5.3 Crown wow super thick
so it's a sea dweller GMT kind of yeah
that's kind of badass now I can see why
they change that right away look they
just made a mistake on the new Explorer
last year with the two short of hands
right they don't say that they made a
mistake this year it came out it said
with extended hands upd upgraded yeah
yeah yeah now these people with the
short hands maybe in 10 years it's like
the shorty explore shorty only one year
well cuz I mean you we were talking like
when the new oyster rep petals came out
I was like these are leftover Milos
cases that they are not selling yeah
these are the white dial milous cases
that they're like uh we got to do
something with this [__] cuz it's like
it's not like Rolex makes a thousand of
and see how they how they do they make
like a million of them like [__] we only
sold 300,000 that's my wife's Grill
watch mil gals love dude like you mean
an old one yeah
yeah9 and I'm like
honey my Grail watch legit is the waffle
dial milal that thing is perfect weird
size case 37 mm that and you guys had HQ
had one a little while ago they had the
it's the oyster Coke courts casee but
it's a date so it's not courts movement
that thing is dope oh the 1530 the 1530
talk about never seeing him that's
another watch I like working on that and
and they were really expensive and then
I sawell something recently some or
someone told me this they were like oh
Rolex or they realized there was a lot
more out there than they thought so they
went from like kind of eight grand down
to back like five or six really yeah cuz
I think they thought they were like
super super rare and they are like you
don't see them very often that dial is
super cool the bracelet is really cool
and weird like if you wanted a Rolex
you're never going to see on someone but
don't want a oy a quartz movement that's
the move it's I mean it's the only watch
for the chapter ring you know yeah it's
so weird looking wait which one with the
chapter ring the 1530 so it's a it's a
um um an oyster quartz case and bracelet
automa but it has an automatic m i mean
and to be fair an oyster quartz was worn
by one of the explorers that went to
Everest like that is a cool watch it's
say I don't want a Rolex with a battery
no no no but the the the way the
bracelet the cases does look really
different to any other roll yeah all
flat surfaces it's just a it's like
futuristic looking in That 70s way
that's love that kind of stuff those are
one of the ones I've seen most trash
those bracelets cuz people have no clue
how to do them what about the stretchy
bracelet didn't even know it existed and
I'm a huge Rolex freak my buddy has a
turnograph brings it out had a stretch
bracelet unbelievable why would they not
make that anymore um did they fall apart
follow is that is that elastic in there
or Springs Springs God damn it's cool my
friend had one they were it's it's
pretty cool oh because you're
comfortable super yeah cuz your wrist
changes all day well that's the beauty
of some of those new tutors is they have
that expanding class CRA which you know
by the end of the day your hand fills
with blood hot swelled up yeah you get
swelled up yeah it's I I think Rolex
will incor incorporate some of the small
things that tutors doing that are
working I think it seems to be the
testing ground like let's see how people
respond to guilt dial you know like this
the kind of more Heritage stuff oh God
it's so great cuz if they did a Heritage
line Rolex and you could get a you know
mil Goos from back in the day style I
mean through the roof through the roof I
I wonder Rolex obviously knows what
they're doing like they do very very
well and I want they they must there's
no way they don't know this [__] and or
at least talk to people about the stuff
they must know like no what we do is we
create new models that become historic
if we look back too much yeah cuz I
almost think
Omega is looking back like a little too
much not a lot I want new models that
like nod the old models but not overdo
it the Explorer to if the case was
smaller would have been a perfect thing
like just the hand yeah just that orange
hand just slap that in there yeah but
like if you go back too far you get in
that weird Bell and Ross Heritage world
where you're like I don't I don't know
about
this is just admitting like our designs
blow ass for a long time yeah like we
man we suck right now like that whereas
like Rolex is like now we make cool ass
watches like I think Sky dwellers are
cool asit I do too let's talk about
the the watch maker at wab by watch told
me he's like I would give anything to
open one of these up because he said he
wants to he's like you adjust you adjust
the whole watch with the bezel is that
true yeah yeah it's crazy crazy the
yacht Master 2 is is very similar okay
now how do you when the when the sky
dweller comes out how do you know how to
work on it does Rolex send you some
schematics or something you open it and
you go holy [__] is it even possible to
get that cuz that's proprietary [__]
yeah for the most part it is well how do
you work on it I've never worked on one
yeah they're not out long enough for
someone to send you one but what would
you do would you be like hey I'm going
to need this for a while reverse
engineer yeah yeah wow I think Sky
dwellers are cool like for like a rich
dude watch if you're like I'm going to
go big if they made it stainless steel
I'd own it the offwhite dial the brown
dial like that thing the white gold one
with the offwhite dial you're like all
right I get it like when it first came
out I was like gross and I saw one
person I was like not gross not too bad
so hip-hop too all the hip-hop world
grabbed it Gold's making a big comeback
gold is 18 just I can't tell you how
many people are like I think I want a
gold watch and they and I'm all our
buddy just bought one yeah to me I think
a gold like 6070s all gold date dress is
is a great value yeah for sure they
saving so much money 183s so just all
day well the day the day date um uh
Platinum that I love with the honeycomb
dial now comes 18 karat with the with
the black with the gold honeycomb dial
yeah that is a [__] Primo watch about
24 Grand uh I mean the 32 or whatever
you can get it for like 24 but that
thing is fire my buddy rolled up to
[__] Starbucks with I was like oh
dick 183s I think are still a really
good value because if I got a gold watch
I don't know if I'd want to wear the
bracelet it's a little too noticeable
yeah so you got to get the oyster
bracelet yeah you get yeah so but even
that I'd probably put it on a strap yeah
so you can get one on a strap for the
same price as a steel sub a nice leather
NATO with Gold Hardware the whole thing
like that would look really really nice
and but I noticed a lot of people are
like I think I want a gold also Walt
Disney wore a gold date drest and so did
Martin Luther King Jr on jubilees like
those things are cool looking dud gold
sub like gold
16 those dials 16808 like with a nipple
dial yeah the gmts are reasonable I mean
the subs are like I see them for like 17
grand but like the gmts are you see them
for 12 it's weird the gmts have
disappeared I've I've so many vintage
gold Subs recently and I can't tell you
the last time I got like a vintage gold
GM two-tone gmts are a good value yeah
on my just bought my bought the floating
dial Daytona gold [__] mint friend
who was he was like I want a gold watch
and I was like I sent him to HQ I was
like you know have you ever looked at a
gold Daytona I'm like this is a '90s
gold Daytona and you're going to saved
10 grand and you're going to be cool as
[__] yeah it's so cool I mean cocaine
that that's why vintage watches really
do it for me it's like you know anybody
with a you know fat bank account can
walk into an authorized dealer and buy
you know but it's the thrill of the hunt
you know for the see but to as a
non-expert the I find the thrill the
hunt a little terrifying yeah so I mean
you seem pretty well vers
yeah but we're scared what's inside yeah
I can't look inside and while I'm
knowledgeable I'm not an expert by any
stretch and as I've been into watches
longer and longer it seems to be like
the actual dealers I'll want to buy from
the pool gets smaller and smaller cuz
even if I hear one story I'm like uhoh
well you're you're right bu the seller
so what do you think what do you think
we you're it's going to make you safe
because uh I was telling Kevin I told
you I I I would buy new watches because
I can't sleep at night with the fear of
six years from now going to get it
serviced and you go dude this is fake if
I had Paul Newman Daytona money I
wouldn't buy one it's too scary yeah
yeah it's literally too scary to me so
what do you think box papers is that
going to keep you safe for me condition
is everything I would much rather have a
super super crisp vintage piece without
Providence as opposed to a shitty overp
polished case and a rough dial of course
but I'm saying for for peace of mind uh
is it just get the piece and come see
you and you open it and go it's real
that'll help I mean the same way you
know when you're when you're buying uh
classic cars get a PPI you know get get
somebody to inspected who doesn't have a
dog in the race and you know yeah yeah
and you just open up and go this is real
yeah a lot of clients do that a lot of
collectors will have you know uh dealers
that that I have a good relationship
with that that we have a dealer account
with that we do a ton of business with
you know just like you you know yasik
had that watch ship to me and you came
and picked it up for me it goes the
opposite way a lot of collectors do that
you know they'll have a dealership a
watch to me you know and not even
necessarily for authentication purposes
just like hey dude check it out see if
it needs service you know see if it
needs anything make sure it's good to go
before I put it on my wrist and take off
and do you charge for that service um
yeah but it's pretty nominal that's what
I'm saying that to me seems like and I
don't know but piece of mind yeah that
to me would be so worth it totally cuz
that feeling you get when you there's a
moment where you're like like wait a
minute yeah it's a pit in your stomach
you're like oh no yeah I really feel
like that I feel hor CU we're not rich
yeah not at all again we we have no
money the health of my dog plays a
larger part in my watch collection than
any other aspect at this point we have
no money so if we have one like my if I
own a watch and you see it on my wrist
it's just straight up my parachute in
case something goes bad I sell it and I
have the money because if money's in the
bank I just burn it up sui and dumb [__]
and it's not going to appreciate right
right so nothing more fears me than um
oh my God this is fake so I'm so glad
that I met you you know what I mean it's
unbelievable pleas what do you think for
people what a big fan of you before you
showed up like the [__] is Dean Del R
doing myice it's so weird when he came
around the corner he goes Dean Del re
I'm you know me I love stand up man you
know I I there's you know I I I really
love
comedy like you obvious viously bur you
know forget about all the classics Carin
and all those guys uh you know love
Rogan Tony
Hinchcliffe uh Diaz is is insane right
now um you know how did how did you get
into comedy CU you were in MMA were you
listening to Rogan's
podcast is that how you found us yeah
wow that's incredible that dude that
podcast is probably bought I think about
the number of Comedy people it's brought
to Comedy and also the careers that it's
launched you know
[__] yeah I Diaz Tony I was on it and I
go all over between Marin Rogan and uh
and Pete Holmes uh I go places and
immediately they're like I heard you on
Rogan I heard like a year ago you did
Jerry right a while ago yeah it was a
year ago yeah I remember listening to
I'm ready to go on again come on
Rogan yeah there's a guy that tweets
Rogan once every 3 months hey have Kevin
Chrissy on I'm like we know each other
he was just talking about people Twitter
bombed him the other day he like dude
that's the last way to get you onast
well that's what we were saying like I
was talking to if he wanted me on he'd
ask me when we're in the
hallway yeah I know it's such it's so
true right like I don't know enough
about space like I don't even like i' be
like yo man I don't know about space
dude some of the guys he has on there
man are just way over my head I had a
great time on we were Ping ponging On
Everything hot rods rock and roll
motorcycles uh life age everything you
know another guy that's into into fun
stuff yeah he is cars and bow hunting if
you had to tell people if someone wants
to buy a Rolex what do you think and
they're like what's the safest Rolex for
me to buy that I don't have to worry so
much about it being fake and it'll just
it'll do everything I'm looking for what
do you tell people St still sub that's
what I say yeah just a just a brand new
one though right just go in and get the
stanless steel set even just like a
pre-owned you know model that's you know
5 10 years old yeah yeah yeah 90 Subs I
think they're the best value in watches
right now tell us have you been to B a
world I have not no you have not no yeah
those are big boys yeah those are big
boys yeah really you should go my
business partners Bon yeah yeah now you
got a partner in the biz you guys have
been in Biz how long were you used to be
downtown yeah yeah but we moved uh to
our location in pastina just in June so
we've only been there a couple months
give all the info on your place yeah
it's Los Angeles watchworks uh you can
find us uh you know our website's Los
Angeles watchworks uh Instagram is La
watchworks uh yeah we're we're in
pastina 2108 Walnut I love you man yeah
thanks and your Instagram is LA Los
Angeles watch yeah yeah because uh and
you need to get some more photos up
there yeah you know I'm too busy working
man I'm like [__] I need post something
the watch game it's it's all about
photos well because you have a gold mine
every day of people bringing in watches
that you can take I just want to see
Parts what I see Parts I'm like that's a
oh I was at a shop dude and we're at
this table and there's dials and there's
movements and there's watches and
there's hands and everything I go wow
how many times have you like coughed and
just shot a spring across the room and
you're on your hands and knees for an
hour trying to find it more times than
I'd like to remember air like loose air
is your enemy wow that is your Darth
Vader like dude like you just someone
like you drop a piece of paper four
watch parts are on the ground yeah [__]
got to be careful freshly sharpened
tweezers are the key to not losing [__]
wow know and and sharp screwdrivers
there's sharp screwdrivers oh yeah a
lang started like a a watchmaker school
and they have some good videos that just
show them people picking stuff up and
I'm like [__] cuz one time someone's
like you should become a watch maker you
like watching so much I was like are you
insane I don't want migraines that level
do you go crazy nah I got you're talking
about school I got a good buddy who's
coming out of rolex's school who just
graduated oh cool yeah is I mean I know
there is a there is a big shortage of
watch makers yeah is it is that
do you think that'll be like a like a
career people could go into because
there's not there's never going to be
enough right yeah just because it's not
a thing people learned how to do yeah I
mean it's definitely you know kind of
looked at as a dying trade but I think
you have to have a certain kind of mind
to do it it's not just it's not like any
other service tra like mic mechanics is
yeah you love it yeah oh I I love
working on watches that's great I you
know I think you'd have to you got yeah
I mean well I mean you know because it's
like a lot of people after a while like
wow I I'm kind of burnt on this you know
what I mean some sometimes you get
frustrated and it gets mundane but I
mean you know then I stop and think like
dude I'm you know I'm getting paid to
work on literally as crazy as it sounds
some of the world's most important
vintage wrist watches like that's
[__] nuts like what was the highest
dollar watch you ever worked on um I
mean there are newans that come through
there do they come in there yeah I've
worked on quite a few newans um and
that's the Valu movement in there is
that what that is yeah Valu 72 let's go
through the movements on the Daytona
it's a Valu then it's Zenith now it's
in-house yep Zenith then inhouse yeah
what's your favorite movement in a
Daytona yeah I like the Zenith no [__]
over the zenth daytonas now are totally
reasonable they're the same as any other
one now which that's crazy to me there
there's still a little up there black di
Zenith you're still going to go 10 plus
but I mean normal day they used to be
such a premium on them MH that's what's
interesting to me is now I noticed just
any chph has gotten kind of expensive
vintage chronographs of all kinds but
like companies like Zenith and actual
Valu and lman are becoming more
collectible cuz now people know like
well that was the movement of this watch
and I'm don't have to spend that money
and it's cool you know it's for like
deep collectors who are looking for like
other stuff to nerd out on that's cool
to me those are the guys that are I mean
collecting for the movement wow that's
cool well yeah that's what well that's
what the original watch collecting was I
absolutely why do you like the Zenith
movement over the new Ro X movement uh a
little more simplistic than the in-house
movement and um just as if not more
robust you know wow really less Parts
wow no [__] huh great great movement to
work on super accurate um you know super
accurate yeah wow that's a good tip
black di Daytona black black Xena
Daytona with like the first year or two
they made it when it didn't have the the
by Tone bracelet it was just a satin
with no block just the fold over dude
that's I've seen what year is that it's
what
90919 yeah early 9091 so it's not a
polished L I would see I would see him
and I'd be like wait did that guy polish
that is that the wrong bracelet and and
I would be like oh my God if that was
real if to me I don't love polished
links I'm not a Polish like like I've
seen like the new GMT and a guy like Tim
was like a guy came in with go give me
that watch and he just took him back and
Polished the links out a lot of guys
send bracelets yeah lot of yeah they
send me GMT bracelets they like just the
bra bracelet how do you do it yeah just
just satin it the the tricky thing with
those is uh is that like Scotch Sprite
no it's it's it's a wheel it's a
proprietary wheel uhhuh what's the
tricky part um the uh the the clasp the
new clasp it's not just you know what I
mean it's like a three-part class
everything has to be Tor it's got a bump
it it it bevs there's like another
stepped up level so on the on the watch
it would be uh that there so it it's
only the band that is the dull part
right is that right on a uh or is there
like a flat part on the watch too on the
I think on the GMT on the GMT there's
like the top of the cas
istin Pol so would you do could you but
that's like old date just too yeah could
you do that you get the new GMT and then
just make it look like a uh uh seed D oh
yeah I would dude I I can do damn near
anything we've done a lot of crazy mods
over the years I've done you know like a
you know like this the finish on the
mill sub cuz the ministry of Defense
didn't want reflected surfes so they add
satin cut sides as well as the tops so
like I've taken like 16610 and 406 not8
subs and done like a mil sub finish dude
we've welded fixed bars like a mil sub
all kinds of crazy stuff that's why
those old Hamilton field watches are
like that
gray blasted yeah they're cool yeah that
so if you do take the shiny middle out
can you restore it back to the way yep
wow that's what the that's what he was
saying he like and if you want it back
when you when you want to sell it like
just bring it back in I'm in on that
because that's why I never like those
other watches because to me there's
nothing more beautiful than the flat
fuckness of a sea dweller man to watch I
think I've I've said I think one of the
main reasons roll for their success is
the oyster bracelet it's such a good
bracelet it fits better than any other
one like it's just perfect looking it's
simple it's thick like it's even the
rivet on like you're like they nailed
the bracelet so early I think that's why
they made just subtle changes over the
years jubilees are great jub fit great
Jubilee to me is such a like 70s
businessman look I love it I like him on
gmts yeah right Jubilee on a GMT is a
must I was looking at that coke on HQ
the one that has replaced hands cuz I
have a Jubilee bracelet I'm like I could
do this right now but I rep GM we got
New Old Stock try man we'll slap I will
talk to you in an hour he's you got New
Old Stock hands are they will they match
though oh yeah dude we've got and it
wasn't my find once again that dial is
is beat wait my my business partner uh
from from a retired watchmaker in
Switzerland bought over a hundred sets
of New Old Stock traum hands
W I was like man are you [__] kidding
me really wow insane [__] yeah so like
you know you get the watch and case is
perfect doll's perfect but it's got
luminova hands cuz serviced it slap on a
new set on hey you're there your watch
search is over I'm probably in cuz that
bezel is faded and sweet looking and
even though the dial is has that track
mark and all the W I was like yeah I
want it beat looking yeah cuz you know
what I love I love that I love Seiko
divers and there's that preaching of the
choir that new there the Pepsi bezel
Seiko diver to me the Patty get the
Patty that thing is so dope looking and
it looks just like a coke with a jubilee
yep that thing and what talk about a
value I have I have every iteration of
the SEO they're i justed b them when
they were dirt cheap too how many
watches you got Personal Collection yep
not not as many as You' think I mean
I've got um like 10 watches and what are
they all Rolexes mostly no uh a few
Rolexes I've got uh a datejust I really
like that was actually my dad's a super
rare sodalite dial really yeah um a
couple Subs uh you know vintage sub
vintage 5513 and then um the new sub uh
man cannot go wrong yep I've got a sea
dweller and a SE dweller what year yeah
uh like 90 it's a triple
six that's my favorite the seed dweller
really like them I love the seed dweller
do you like it yeah oh I love it dude
the ultimate tool watch yeah yeah right
goes deeper and harder than anything
else it's bulletproof I like the old ads
for the sea dweller too the in National
Geographic yeah like those are pretty
sweet do you like the new seed dweller
oh yeah the seed dweller 4,000 yeah the
the deep sea is a little big that's good
hug but the C 4000 is they made a
mistake with the band on the deep sea if
they put a big band on it it'd be
phenomenal it's the the body's weird at
the lugs it's okay but they tapered it
too small should have kept it at 20 yeah
they should have kept it at 20 and they
would be it would be a Grail watch for
everyone yeah that would have been a
real popular one from there my
collection's mostly mostly weird stuff a
lot of seyo divers you know the they're
[__] awesome everywhere from the 6217
all the way up so the there the 61 105
the
6309 um a bunch of versions of like the
modern divers do you like what's what's
the what's the space one they call it
the POG the POG yeah you have one of
those I don't I had I got one of those I
got a pretty wab by watch has a seyo box
cuz for them it's not worth them to sell
them really they don't make enough
profit and he was like you know we have
a box I got to go see Ken and dig into
that box he's got some good ones he's
got like the root beer one he's got
another one of The Pogues he had like
and you know how much are they they're
like in the low hundreds like I think I
paid 400 bucks for my such cool watches
man such little money is that a manual
wind or automatic uh the pok's automatic
I think automatic it's automatic that's
what sucks about the divers you can't
wind them on the crown you got to shake
them yeah I can't do you prefer
automatic or manual most watch Freaks or
manual right um either way I mean it
depends on the watch if we're you know
if we're talking old school military
watches then yeah manual a lot of a lot
of collectors that's why like the early
historic paniz a lot of collectors like
just the act of waking up having that
alone time you know I liked winding my
flipping a record man it's like flipping
a record that's what was so great about
that Lang man it the smoothest wind
you've like it didn't it was incredible
I love that I shouldn't have sold that
thing man God damn it I like the uh you
know like eight day movements like you
know you wind it up it's good for eight
days that [__] right eight day movements
twin barrel I love that stuff but I
can't stand when they put the gauge on
the front eight days you know with the
little arm that goes down I like on the
when they did it right is the Pam 190
it's a radio mirror and it's actually
got a jlc movement and um you know it's
got a uh the the Showcase back you know
it's got a sapphire back so you can see
and the the uh Power Reserve meter is on
the flip side I saw that I saw that it's
it's amazing back there I think jlc's
are underrated too they're kick ass jlc
yeah yeah that especially the old ones
like old memo voxes are sweet looking I
just did a s old jlc super compressor
for a guy oh yeah how many watches do
you do a
week 2530 [__] now keep in mind not
full movement Services right right I get
it I get it but just states of
restoration how long does it take to to
full movement service like a sub if
someone just a 90 sub like a very Norm
just and not nothing's wrong with it
you're just like yo it probably hasn't
been service in a decade can you are we
talking the like our service queue or
actually just from start to finish
taking the watch part and servicing it
taking it apart and servicing it two
days two days two days Jesus wow and
that includes QC cuz you know I mean you
you got to you got to test okay now how
often should people get their rox's as
service they saying that we can go five
years now the industry standards five
years but I mean you know between
between five and 10 yeah yeah as soon as
it starts out running weird right bring
it in I've got a uh I've got a client
we've had for years a diver he was a
commercial diver like an underwater
welder oh yeah his whole career and now
he just diver yeah now he's just now
he's just a recreational diver you know
he's retired but he's got a 1680 so you
know vintage sub and he's logged over
1100 Dives on it 1,00 Dives any Services
yeah oh he comes in every couple years
he comes in every couple years and we do
all new gaskets a new Crystal because he
beats the [__] out of the acry that Top
Hat Crystal seems to me to be ripe for
the water making its way inside no no no
the acry crystal is actually a great
design it because um under pressure they
Flex sapphires don't wow but yeah he
comes in he comes in every couple years
and he gets all new gaskets a new
Crystal and then we'll you know we'll do
a full depth pressure test back out to
dive now you did a dep pressure test
while I was there and that machine what
does that machine cost big money the
Poseidon it's yeah it's like five grand
it's so weird it was just called up
aside it was a small box he stuck it in
there and it just [__] did pressure
on it and now what what' you say it
shoots water inside and then it like
releases no it it pressurizes the
chamber to uh you know for you know a
dive watch we'd go up to like 10 bars so
and if there's any uh if there's any
variance they know it's get it knows
it's getting into the watch and it'll
fail the test so the pressure in the
chamber changes because the water ising
inside the watch wow and after that if
we're talking Deep dive like sat diving
you mentioned the sea dwellers we have a
rocker wet tester okay
that goes up to damn like 100 bars or
something you had that weird old one
from like the 40s or whatever looked
like a the vintage Rolex one yeah yeah
that thing was sick man we don't use it
anymore but it's it's very cool piece
have you seen those weird bracelets some
guys making they look like sub bezels oh
yeah yeah they're pretty funny looking
they're coming out of Hong Kong in
Plains yeah I'm not mad at them like I
saw I was like yeah okay
yeah dude thanks for doing the show man
my pleasure Dean abolutely it's so great
you got to come out and do some comedy
and I'll take Kev up to the shop great
and uh and we'll just come up for a day
hopefully he'll get that watch and we'll
bring it up and get some hands on there
might be there this week yeah we'll get
some hands on it put that Jubilee and
just hang out and have lunch beautiful
dude once again name of the shop your
watch man huh your watch we got to get
your watch yeah yeah yeah
yeah here we go unboxing
yeah here we
go
okay so it was running 30 seconds ahead
yeah it was 30 seconds fast to day and
is that what why is that is it is there
like a spring that's too tight no they
just just get out of adjustment over the
years did you clean the whole thing uh
we we did what we call a vintage ref
finish on that so we we left this we
left the Polish sides alone all we did
is just sharpen up the shamers and and
recut the tops to Lug so they're super
sharp look at that thing dude whoa
anything on the strap Yeah clean up
clean up
the sharp as hell dude see that's the
thing it's new looking brand new that
was what was so confusing by that
picture I like wait dude the band looks
brand new in my head I honestly thought
you guys were taking molten steel yeah
giving a thin skin of it like dipping
the watch in molten steel and then laser
cutting a basically a case from like
some weird schematic that you had in a
laser cutting machine I was like that's
the only way this makes sense look at
this thing though that the [__] what
do you do what' you do to the strap it
looks brand new yeah just fresh satin
fresh satin like like what you like you
put something on it yeah well just uh
you know we use a satin wheel
proprietory unbelievable this [__]
thing that thing is new wow my pleasure
bro now here's the only mark on it the B
yeah ah you're going to scratch it
anyway but I didn't do it can you get me
me one if I trade it in we could
probably get you one all right cool I'm
in [__] dude this is incredible nice wow
man that is insane now it was running 30
seconds fast right how does that happen
uh it just gets out of out of adjustment
over the years yeah same way your valves
need adjusted on your car yeah yeah it's
weird that something getting maybe
potentially looser would make it run
faster yeah yeah right or maybe it's
it's gra maybe it's gravity I don't know
I go either way look at this thing dude
I mean cuz you know like I was thinking
like oh cuz he looked at it with the
[__] thing and he goes it's been a
hair polished probably with a cloth or
something not shining it up K yeah
because it uh you know to the naked eye
it looked unpolished but he looked at it
right away yeah I can just tell and then
and then I was like get rid of that but
now it's like a lifer watch yeah we we
bring him back to man oh my god dude
thank you so much wow all right uh
thanks a lot for tuning in guys to the
ultimate nerding of uh watch
watching we did a watch episode of my
podcast but we couldn't answer any
questions cuz there was no other expert
it was just me going I mean I like the
color of this one dude great time guys
[__] thanks D this kill glad you like it
wow wear it in good health yeah